on va pas habiter avec valmer 150 mètres
carrés on trouvera jamais mieux
[Musique]
qu'est ce tu fais là je vais me
rencontrer mes nouveaux collègues
moi je m'en fous de lui un c'est juste
un mec sain j'ai réfléchi mais tu feras
même entraînant sais pas si je n'avais
jamais eu un poil en fait un elodie
dufau sa meuf
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est bien c'est qu'en fait on est
tous potes et c'était beaucoup plus
facile de travailler ensemble beaucoup
plus facile la complicité qu'on avait
déjà en train de troie parce que c'est
important d'avoir les danseurs plus le
chorégraphe qui s'entendent bien et
comme ça si eux ils ont des suggestions
je prends tout le temps je sais se
passer à merveille
on est beaucoup de salto pour iam je me
suis dit 'c'est l'acrobate il faut qu'on
passe des trucs impressionnants
j'ai vu faire des idées des philippins
des salles peu en arrière des supérieurs
vous allez voir une petite vries et
c'est assez flippant et et lui il
fallait juste que je la fasse un peu
plus bouger on la rend très sexy savait
déjà que les deux ça marche super bien
on dirait que c'est des meilleurs amis
qui se connaissent depuis des années des
années
alors du coup la complicité qu'on
voulait créer dans cette province
c'était en jean de amitié qu'ils ont on
sent qu'il ya une petite attraction le
fait de s'entendre aussi bien je pense
que ça aide que la danse soit encore
plus fluide et plus belle
[Musique]